apparemment c'était 10 missiles
balistiques de type Iskender qui ont été
lancés vers la capitale
ukrainienne aux alentours de 3 heures du
matin heure locale les autorités disent
que tous ont été interceptés mais comme
vous voyez derrière moi non sans faire
des décales bâtiment derrière moi il y a
des vitres brisées à tous les étages les
habitants sont en train de nettoyer les
débris ce matin et puis c'est
ma droite qu'il y a une clinique
d'enfants qui a aussi été endommagé un
enfant est mort ce n'est pas un patient
de la clinique en fait qui travaille que
en journée apparemment c'était des
enfants qui couraient vers l'abri et le
débris est tombée au moment où il
courait ils ont pas eu le temps
d'atteindre l'abri où il cherchait à se
rendre parce que le bâtiment où ils
habitent n'a pas d'abri ça c'est parce
que les missiles sont arrivés au-dessus
de Kiev très rapidement après l'annonce
de l'alerte anti-aérienne juste quelques
minutes cela je l'ai entendu moi-même
aussi là on est rive gauche donc à l'est
de la capitale dans le centre-ville
aussi on entendait très très fort le
bruit du travail des systèmes de défense
solaire je pense que ce n'est pas
uniquement ce district où je me trouve
en ce moment qui a été frappé deux
autres districts au moins ont vu des
fragments de requête tomber et faire
quelques dégâts 10 personnes ont dû être
hospitalisés